[Music]  Kove answer maxes out Kath last last  season Shara was injured I mean you've  competed in at the highest level the  world level how's your body feeling how  are you handling all these moves and  twists and turns and spins I'm super  sore are you I came in with an injury so  it's a little challenging like I need  surgery on my spine when I'm done but  but doing this like my heels feel like  little blades I keep putting my feet  they're so bruised  seven cuts on each meeting um I have a  couple herniated discs stenosis  arthritis I just it's it's really nice  little skinny arm does I have like a lot  of atropine muscles so I don't know it's  yeah that's good I'm probably 40 years  of falling falling and jumping and  falling and hanging in keep doing what  you're doing  Thanks  [Music]